good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy hump
day it is wednesday so do not forget
to not only acknowledge the space that
you're in but also hump someone you love
i have theo here today thank god so i'm
all taken care of
you're going home to bruce after this
you're all taken care of that's all we
could ask for
yes acknowledge the space that you're in
and inevitably you will hum someone you
love
once you do that acknowledgement
nevertheless you will hum
i before we go any further i need you to
acknowledge the space that you're
in one in which you stand corrected
if you're watching on youtube claudia's
hair looks sickening
the roots down okay yes
yes but it's not from the dyson air app
like
okay we all saw your tick tock so yeah i
did this tick tock oh
sorry your take time i know i did this
tick tock because i really wanted to
give this stupid 600
blow dryer another chance because like i
literally already spent money it's been
sitting under my desk
and i got to work and the final product
looked pretty good
um the final product was
never seen again like literally when i
got into bed at night like my hair was
back to
natural yeah it takes some maintenance
it's not perfect
so but then don't charge me 600 if
there's a learning curve it's not
perfect and i have to redo it in the
morning
so this morning i used a flat iron like
i i made used other tools
so you didn't use the flip trick i
taught you no i used my revlon round
brush which by the way like fifty
dollars
the dyson air rope wishes she could be
the revlon one step well we all saw your
tick tock and it looked amazing i know
and now i feel like i
put out misinformation even though you
begrudgingly like had a sickening hairdo
you couldn't stop the results from being
what they were no i know and like i i
wanted to be wrong like
i spent that money i want to have an
easy time doing my hair
okay so you're saying you're done with
the dyson like i don't see a reason to
keep her because i have a number of
people in my dms
who sent me their addresses who want you
to send it to me too once i decide to
fully let go from it i'm literally just
going to choose someone and like
surprise them with it i think that's
really good i'll clean it first i've
only used it like four times
i think that's great i haven't used most
of the extensions great
everybody wins so i just don't like i
don't know
i don't know that's all i'll say like i
don't know i'm in this like really kind
of
confusing space and i don't know how to
acknowledge the space that i'm currently
in because i can't really define the
space like how i'm feeling
well you know that in itself is a space
so true limbo
the space of confusion purgatory yeah
yeah so
take your time it'll it'll solve itself
don't worry about it yeah i know
i'm just like i know i have a new
haircut so like i'm just kind of
figuring out how to style it
and i thought the dyson air wrap would
like truly
enlighten the new haircut and if
anything i'm left more confused
well uh your hair looks great today
thank you so whatever you did or learned
keep doing and learn great but you never
styled it like this before so like it
took well because no it's my short hair
i only style it like this when i have
short hair
it looks great thank you so much so
thank you thank you for the
encouragement on the journey i truly
appreciate it you're welcome i'm
nothing if not encouraging so true
unlike you who is just not encouraging
my wellness journey okay tell them
tell them tell them and i bet they'll
agree with me
tell them so yeah he's been accusing me
of not being
screaming at me to tell them jackie's
being accusing me i just wanted to set
the stage sorry okay
so i said yesterday that i was gonna go
to a wellness retreat like my friend had
recommended it and i did a little
research and it looked so fabulous and i
know two people who went there and love
it
utterly fabulous really expensive though
but i was going insane i was going to
make peace with the price and so i
reached out at but they're completely
booked until july which like doesn't
help me i want to go in two weeks
which was a blessing because it's
literally an insane amount of money to
spend on a week right
even even on a vacation like right i
need to get my wellness
like on and pop it on fleek so i'm
wanting to go sooner but now that like
i i started to like think about going on
a wellness routine i was like wow i
really want to do this so
i start john phonics i was hooked on
wellness so i started
but also when i say wellness like it's
also just like i want to get like it's
getting in shape like a canyon ranch
yeah like a lose weight feel great
clear your mind and body and soul
exactly it's mental
and it's physical so it's both um it's
not just like a healing trip where i'm
going to do that
no no you want to like you want me to do
fitness and i'm going to eat right you
want to go to fat camp for a week
yes so i'm going to get my mind in my
body right um so
i was really like excited to do this one
but then i couldn't get
a slot so i started doing some research
and i found a different program
that i'm not going to like put no don't
put them on loss right no because i'm i
still might do it you're just like not
being supportive but i found a program
that's literally
just like a weight loss camp for a week
um and it looks like so great
and serious and i want to go
i want to go they have a spot for me
okay the week that i want to go
by the way i support you because this
one's reasonably priced and if you want
to be a freak and spend an entire week
like
in a torture chamber like that's on you
i'm supportive of that
what i'm not supportive of is you trying
to get me to come with you
oh i mean i gave up on that i tried i
tried
no i had zach would come with me he said
he said like if i couldn't find someone
to come with me that he would come and
that's his job as a husband and it's pet
friendly so bruno is coming too
i am supportive of this journey yeah
this is 25 percent of the price
i heard you in centralized drinks last
night just like talking about how crazy
it was
no looking did you [ __ ] snitch
looking at the instagram account
oh my god that [ __ ] [ __ ] okay ready
i did not she brought it up margo
and she was like she's like she's trying
to get me to come with i'm like yeah she
already started on me like she knows
i literally called ben i called everyone
i said jackie knows better than like
first of all i don't do things i don't
want to do and i
certainly don't go to weight loss
retreats so like i'm literally the last
person in the family who would
literally ever go and margo's actually
like a
a decent candidate to be persuaded by
you i thought so too so she was like
adamant and so she was trying to tell me
to like like to tell you to like lay off
at first i can't believe she would even
[ __ ] bring that up
interesting and i was just like this new
place
we were talking about how when you
wanted to spend the money at the fancy
place like we thought you were [ __ ]
crazy
okay and then with this place like happy
for you but we did look up some pictures
of the facility
and it does appear to be you know
a cabin in the woods so that's what i'm
saying it's rustic okay
it's a camp as long as you know what
you're signing up for and like no one is
gonna like sell you
into a cult then go and live your best
life i have been supportive
of that i've just been looking out for
your finances sorry
okay fine i just would really like to
feel some supportive energy as
i try to make this decision i know but
you know what now that i know no no no
this morning i was leaning towards like
maybe not going because it does feel
extreme but now that i've said it on the
show like i think i need to
i think i have to go no the thing is is
that i have actually not been
unsupportive at all i've just been kind
of like realistic which i know is like
not what you want to hear
um and i think maybe you like coming at
me saying i'm being unsupportive
is kind of what you're feeling inside
like maybe i shouldn't go and you're
trying to blame me no i'm just looking
for like one person
to like encourage me because it's like
it's a big decision to make you know i'm
just looking for like i want to be
encouraged to go
and so when everyone's like being a
bunch of naysayers
well also you know this is what
counselor and i were saying like i just
worry about your expectations because
like
you are only going to be away for like
six days whatever and like one of them
is a travel day so like you know
you're not really gonna be there for so
long the expectations of the weight loss
you need no of just like you said you're
gonna come out a different person like
it's only a week even like on the
you know best most healthiest journey
you're still the same person a week
later so like
i don't think i'm going to come out a
new person i think it's going to
jumpstart something for me that i've
been having a hard time starting myself
okay i support anything you want to do
that's
financial and financially reasonable
okay um and this new facility is
um i don't think you'll have a good time
but
sometimes self-care looks like hard work
go for it
okay thank you for this about face what
does that mean
changing of the way that i have not said
anything different than i've been saying
to you all week
i didn't i would be i will be very
outspoken i did not support the first
place
maybe it's just like it was lost in like
communication over face time i wasn't
feeling supported but like
here face to face but i don't really
know how you could say you weren't
feeling supported because
first of all i support you and i wanted
to look out for you and i think you
spending that money on the first place
was so silly
and we agree on that right now i don't
know i think you get what you pay for
okay that but then the second thing was
like you coming for me asking me to go
with you like
that was kind of crossing a line in my
book okay um
sorry that i want to spend time with you
that's not what it is you just don't
want to go to a place alone like in case
they murder you it's like now i have to
get murdered too because you wanted to
lose five pounds like yeah that's not
worth it
um i don't know i think that's being a
good sister
it's honestly going above and beyond as
a sister and i think we all love them
yes i'm not that type of sister you are
yes so that's why i was just like hoping
someone could be that for me
but no you're asking a lot like you
really are it's fine
i'm going to make peace with the journey
and now that i've said it out loud on
the show
i think i have to go okay and it will be
an experience and i will be vlogging it
of course of course if anything do it
for the vlog hundred percent
so in this one month of patreon you'll
get our krispy kreme total house pie
vlog which the tall house pie was
finally delivered today that's what
we've been waiting
for so we are filming it today it just
got delivered so you'll get your krispy
kreme vlog
and your weight loss journey vlog and if
you're ever curious as to why we have to
go on
weight loss journey vlogs it's because
you'll refer to the krispy kreme right
right right yeah um well it's also
wednesday so we have your toasters which
i'm super excited about our advice
segment so that'll be at the end of the
show
and real housewives of dallas was on
last night and it's actually a pretty
good episode it was pretty good i caught
up
so i'm kept abreast and yeah i have some
thoughts about
oklahoma talks about carrie gotta i have
thoughts about harry thoughts on um
our possible move to oklahoma i think
that's the place for us yeah
no i think you might be onto something
no i think stephanie holman
might have been onto something when she
decided to be born there yeah no
she did that um so yeah what else did
you do yesterday i don't like yesterday
it was like a blurb
it was like busy i did a lot of errands
and i did like a lot of stuff
that i've been putting off you know like
ben literally posted a meme yesterday
that spoke to my soul yes
um where it was like you wait 16 days to
do a task not even 60 days like six
months to do a test that took you 15
minutes and you learn nothing from and
then you're gonna do it that way again
but yesterday like i did do a bunch of
stuff i had been putting off
um i just like i well actually it wasn't
that productive because i had to pick up
a prescription but the line was really
long so i left okay
dropped off some things at the dry
cleaning literally one sweater that's
been waiting to go to dry cleaning since
november
dry cleaning is like the most
annoying errand because first of all
it's going to keep accruing so i might
as well just like keep the pile going i
know but it's like if
i'm getting a dry clean it means like i
wore it which means it's like one of
five things that i enjoy wearing right
now
and i need it back but also i hate dry
cleaning because i hate getting dry
cleaning back like
having to unwrap so much paper plastic
wire hanger finding a new fresh hanger
hanging it up like it's
then it's like a job for me mm-hmm so
now that's not for me
i'd rather just never wear that sweater
again yeah no but i've been needing the
sweater like every outfit has been
calling for the sweater when you guys
see it you'll know it like you'll know
it when you see it
speaking of sweaters i got a new one
cool i'm wearing today speaking of
sweaters um
this one's old it looks cute nonetheless
oh my timehop is starting to trigger me
like hardcore now can anyone relate to
this because
i guess this time last year we were like
peak activities in quarantine so like
literally my um my timehop is reminding
me of like all the puzzles
all the meals rupaul's drag race
remember when i was knitting like
oh my god i'm feeling so triggered i
don't know what to do like i can't look
at time up anymore you know what
it's about to get worse because we still
haven't hit zoom toast
in time hop we were still in studio so
at least like you were
leaving the house and getting dressed
and like it was still inside
my normal looking fun like quirky phase
and
then zoom toast comes along and this is
something we're gonna have to deal with
every year for the rest of our lives
like time hop is seriously
i might have to delete it just because
it's not like a certain time of year
where we'll
get the quarantine it'll be all [ __ ]
year yeah but maybe you just eventually
delete all the pictures from your phone
so that there aren't so many coming up
in your timehop it's really triggering
like delete this year from your phone
yeah think about it i will
speaking of things to think about
redhead madness finals are
underway top two before we were
strangers versus girl with no job
the preliminary polls are showing that
before we were strangers who's gonna
take the win
i'm not like of course like i'm a little
like of course you always want to win
of course but like okay well i'm a
little bit more disappointed than i
thought it would be because i really
like
it really was an honor to be nominated
but then i'm like what if i just took
this whole thing
but i didn't because that's not me and
that's fine i'm a first-time author
and you know before i wrote my book i
could barely read so this is truly an
honor
thank you to the redheads community for
always supporting me and honestly
even just to be on the same bracket as
some of these esteemed
authors is so humbling and and
gratifying in so many ways so i just
want to say thank you
and even though i couldn't win this time
i'm really i am at peace with that like
i really am and i'm just
so honored to have made it to even past
the first round like
is a huge deal for me so you're number
two out of 18 which that's
pretty darn good especially because we
have some we've read some really good
books
and you told me that i made the
semi-finals which was top four and like
with for that like i was
happy like i did not need to move i
needed i didn't did not need to advance
to another round
and i made it one more round so two more
rounds so like no
one more round yeah so i'm really
gonna acknowledge the space that i'm in
and feel really positive about it so
thank you to the redheads community i
love you guys and also we think that
you've been awarded miss congeniality
amongst the authors oh really well
yeah there's been so many authors come
on the show um so it's nice to you know
kind of win that
yeah you know just the small things it
is what it is
it is what it is so thanks everyone for
voting and that was really fun
yeah it was it was like a good activity
for us it was what did we do next
i don't know but now i'm gonna like go
through all the scores and and write
down
ten right right um so that was fun and
i started a new book last night i can't
remember the name but it's about
napoleon's wife
i think i don't know so far so good oh
little french
revolution drama tudor vibe no it's
actually like bonaparte vibes
oh louis spun apart napoleon napoleon
mona parte
yeah okay um well happy for you thank
you that i am
and i think we should dive in because
there's a lot to cover i do i think
without
further a do where
are you last day yesterday i called her
thelma when her name is velma you called
her velma
when her name miss thelma for real and
now you called her selma
what her name is elma which is so bad
it's thelma
what is it but you said valma her name
is stelma
no her name is velma
but i said elmo i'm sorry velma
for calling you thelma nope nope no wait
this is chris pine what's the [ __ ] is
her name velma
or velma and her name is thelma or velma
i guess we'll never know without further
ado
it is time for the fast life stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
hit him with that crooch
okay let me uh take a wild guess what's
today's episode brought to you by
hmm well if we were just singing doo doo
doo doo
then the next association would be
brutal
thank you so much so much brings us to
the brood
and you come as a shock to absolutely no
one that today's episode is brought to
you by bruce the official toothbrush of
the morning toast
and the toaster community the best
electric toothbrush on the market says
me says jackie
and says thousands of happy morning
toast customers
bruce is a very reasonably priced
electric toothbrush some electric
toothbrushes on the market can go for
over 200
which is kind of insane to spend on a
toothbrush but bruce has got your back
because it's very reasonably priced
lasts very long is super well designed
very sleek and it's everything you need
to make your bathroom counter just like
yeezy level uh thickness thickening the
counters down
the brush itself comes with six unique
modes to customize your brushing
experience
the battery life lasts four weeks and it
comes with a magnetic charging stand and
a compact
travel case they also have a
subscription program so you never forget
to change your brush head again
bruce will ship you a new replacement
head every six months so you're never
stuck using a worn down brush head
the design is very sleek their electric
toothbrush has a modern aesthetically
pleasing design
that comes in trend driven seasonal
colors and it looks great on your
bathroom counter
get fifteen percent off your brush
toothbrush kit and the refill plan
when you use the promo code toast at
bruce.com that's 15
off using promo code toast at brush.com
promo code toast at bruush.com
join the thousands of happy toasters and
customers who have changed their life
their gums their teeth their breath
thanks to bruce bruce.com love it
okay first story andy cohen announces
watch what happens live special with the
real housewives children
so before we even dive into the cast
like i just want to talk about this
conceptually because i have a lot of
problems with the cast
mainly one brooks marks um let's dive
into the cast but i just want to say
like as an idea like
who whoever came up with this idea like
is an absolute genius because i was just
on tick tock
getting old clips from watch weapons
live live in los angeles and it was just
like such an
event and it was like we haven't had
that in so long like bravocon
it was just a genius and we just need
something fresh
yes and i love this idea my only gripe
with it is that
it's probably going to be virtual which
just like takes away
from the excitement of all these kids
getting together like and meeting who
knows like brilliant
and frank kentania like getting along
brielle and frank
brielle and frank forever oh my god
totally but you're right now that i know
you're right i didn't even think about
that it's definitely on zoom and so
um let's get into the cast but i also
think that this is going to be a
mother's day special that seems like yes
andy announced that he's hosting a bravo
kids episode of watch what happens live
with andy cohen that's set to feature
kim zolciak's daughter brielle berman
oh real bourbon she's jewish now
okay let's just go off like brielle
biermann perfect for this
og has been through a lot of different
seasons
on bravo and she has her own show and
she's everything of the sort done
riley burris who's candy's daughter
loves same energy as brielle been there
forever
has a personality like we love to see it
love to see it dolores
son frankie catania everything of the
sort
yeah i hope he wears one of those tuxedo
tuxedos from
mel zones how do you remember that
if you guys were around that's what i'm
here for in the toast era for the mel
zone era like that was
like honestly my favorite time to be
alive 100. teresa's daughter gia giudice
perfect same as brielle biermann and
icon i think it was a great selection
vicky's daughter brianna culverson so
yeah she's not a kid that's a thing she
has kids so i get it's like their
parents were bravo but i didn't like
brianna even when she brianna when even
when she was on the show
um and i just i i didn't i wasn't
pleased with the selection
even though she is like the
quintessential og bravo child like she
grew up on the show
yes but one i agree like so far
everyone's around the same age like
what romances are going to be popping
off and this seems like a
choice plus vicky's not even housewife
anymore so like you guys made that
decision
true also gina keogh next gina keough's
son
shane another one same exact thought
process
yeah but now it's like bringing me back
to like those early seasons
of oc when like it was literally all
about the kids and it was like so crazy
yeah luanne's daughter victoria perfect
caroline manzo's sons albie and chris
they're so funny they have such great
personalities i cannot wait for them
okay but like the same exact thing could
be said which is like they're old
and older and their mom's not on the
show
okay true but they're in they're not as
old
as brianna and they don't have kids so
like something about i don't think they
don't
i agree there's something about them
doesn't bother me but something about
brianna does sorry i don't why do i have
to explain myself
okay i just wanted you to like no i know
i'm just coming up with reasons i just
like i'm not
i'm just like no no i completely agree
with you i just wanted to call us out on
our own hypocrites biases yeah no i
definitely i
do not know this like i'm literally the
most hypocritical [ __ ] on this planet
okay
cool meredith sun brooks so this is
where i really have a problem let me
tell you why not only not because i
don't like brooks because i don't like
brooks but that's not why like
i just think it's like this is meant to
be like a celebration of history
and brooks has just like just got here
like yeah he hasn't
burned his stripes yet even though he
put them on his tracks yes
um you know i literally was four inches
away from buying a tracksuit yesterday
it would it's just as a joke and it
would look good um
for a sweatshirt literally from american
apparel and sweatpants from american
apparel up 200
no thank you each 175 and no 125 and
like 75 for the pants like it added up
to like over 200 dollars
wow yeah so i was just like okay this is
like a practical joke but at what
expense you know i know
literally literally um i agree with you
like everyone else has been on the show
multiple seasons knows each other
played their dues yeah we and brooks
just it's
he's not at that level yet no and
honestly like so much of what i hope
they ask is like what was it like like
going to school and like
being a kid when all of this was
happening and brooks doesn't know he
doesn't he drops out of college and he's
been on it for one year yeah like i want
to hear what it was like for avery
singer to go to these like snooty you
know upper east side private schools
when her mom was like getting drunk on
television like how does that work
yeah cynthia bailey's daughter noel live
for her she's gorgeous
ramona's daughter avery perfect like
perfect and cheray's son cairo
oh okay so for the most part i think
they did a really good job with casting
i just have like a huge
issue with brooke's marks yeah i agree
but if everything else
you know is good then i'm not gonna harp
on the one
me too on the one and i think this will
be great i just really wish it were in
person because like i think so many
love connections could be made and even
friendships
yeah no but there's definitely something
a bruin between brielle
and frank frankie yeah excuse me i
i ship and like are the parents gonna
like be involved at all like i wish it
was in studio so like the parents could
be in the audience like that would be
funny yeah and why that's like
in new york now like you can gather in
groups of less than 50 years
i mean maybe it will be in person i'm
just assuming it will be virtual but
let's hold out hope that will be in
person that would be
so enjoyable and also in may because now
i think i was watching i wasn't watching
but new york one just like happened to
be on
and i think i heard them say that um
every adult in new york is now eligible
for
the vaccine um april they moved it to
now everyone over 30
as of yesterday everyone over 16
every adult yeah so yeah so like why not
do it in may
yeah hopefully that would be fabulous i
love this idea i love the cast for the
most part
and i hope andy's excited because you
know sometimes when you're watching
watch what happens live you can
feel that andy would literally rather be
anywhere else but his own studio
um and it's like frustrating and that
really happens a lot with like the bravo
people not with like true celebrities
so i hope he um is in a good mood that
day yeah
i think he will be this is the first of
its kind and i think he will
enjoy the process yeah so if you want to
submit questions head over to his
facebook page and also twitter now they
just um
opened it up yeah okay next up a little
new relationship news sophia
richie is dating someone new and her
family approves oh okay well they didn't
approve last time
sophia well i think eventually they did
but lionel took a while to come around
as he should sophia richie has a new man
in her life a source tells entertainment
tonight that the 22 year old model is
dating elliot grange
a music executive okay businessman beau
a businessman bo
they have been friends for years and
elliott is also close with sophia's
brother miles the source says of
richie's 26 year old brother
it's very nice for sofia to date someone
who her family approves of and likes
how old is this man the article does not
specify that was of course like my first
question yeah but i'm gonna
venture to guess he's around 26 because
he's friends with her brother
right thank you great yeah i'm really
happy for her like
i it must be tough that like
scott moved on so publicly and so fast
um
and i like that she's taking this kind
of like low-key approach with a
businessman but i have a lot of respect
for that
and i really like sofia also the last
person that she was spotted out with was
also a businessman bow i believe so she
clearly is into
businessmen and maybe she like saw you
know the life of like a
star and didn't want that so now she
went to the other side of the industry
yeah for sure except for her industry
executive
um the entire hamline um family is
on vacation and i'm like so curious if
scott is there are they in miami
they were somewhere tropical well scott
was in miami i think
so like i'm just curious i couldn't like
yes i'm curious like i just want to know
but i'm not going to do any sort of like
stalking investigating like i'm not
going to support this in any way
no me neither and like i really hope
lisa like kind of has to
um like explain it on
the new season of beverly hills because
they've been together for a while and
it's definitely gonna come up at some
point in the filming
yeah and like what do you have any
concerns about the fact lisa's like so
obsessed with fame the hustle like she
and she probably like is living for the
fact that her daughter's dating someone
so famous but like there isn't
like an actual concern about like how
young she is and
how old he is and i'm curious if she's
even gonna address that yeah but also
delilah and amelia have been on the show
before
so now that they're like actually in the
headlines like that would be the time to
come on the show right like not before
we didn't know who you were like now we
like live for you like give us more
yeah i live i i do
lisa really saw the bella and gigi
um model like take off and she want like
wanted the same thing
but that's not what she got no no but
like it was very much appeared to be
like the same type of
yes set up yes i i agree and i think
bravo wanted that too
yeah no i mean it was so great for bravo
like the fact
this is why i love bravo the fact that
gigi hadid
was on the biggest supermodel in the
world was on the real housewives of
beverly hills
for multiple seasons and like was doing
photo shoots for guests and like
complaining about how she was hungry and
her mom said she could only eat almonds
like
that is a cultural phenomenon and like
the fact that we kind of lived through
it like we were so lucky yeah
it was iconic and so many like young
girls myself included like became
obsessed with gigi from that show
yeah good times crazy times those were
good times that was like the peak of
beverly hills the dream team
like dream team brandy lisa van i can't
believe i used to love lisa vanderpump
like those were just like the glory days
those were the glory days like brandy i
loved her so much i loved yolanda
and i loved her them too and lisa like
as a unit but then it all really kind of
fell apart when brandon glanville
started making like nasty comments to
yolanda about bella hadid's dui at age
14 you know
oh they were sitting by their pool you
know yeah
and that house was so iconic the fridge
the grass the argyle grass in the
backyard
i would do anything to live in that
house but then like nothing it turned
like
now looking at it all in hindsight like
the david foster over at all like it was
not anything of the sort like between
them you know no but what was watching
sustainable
no of course not but what we were
watching was truly like just a fantasy
yeah and i loved living in the fantasy
but fantasies don't last forever
no they don't clearly are you ready for
our next story
pete davidson is moving out of his mom's
house he must be getting serious
i got a pad pete davidson at 27 years
old has officially left the nest oh my
god
pete davidson and i are like the same
age yeah
that's crazy did you think he was older
or younger older oh no but he's like
known for being young but like now the
young guy is 27 so like
we're all getting old yeah right like
i'm i'm old yeah oh interesting okay
he's moved into a place of his own two
years after buying a home with his mom
amy he shared on tick tock that quote i
just moved out of my mom's house i'm
fully out i got a pad
the brief clip showed his living area i
had tall windows a large tv and a few
pictures
did it look like the city like no it's
in staten island oh my god i love how
he's like so obsessed with his hometown
yeah i mean i do think it's time even
though like
he converted the hell out of his mom's
basement like i saw a tour once for like
a netflix
to promote his stand-up special yeah he
did like a tour like a crib style tour
for netflix's instagram
and it was like super nice like it was
decked the [ __ ] out like you would never
know it was his mom's basement in staten
island like it looked like a penthouse
like
you know framed basketball jerseys
everywhere like video games like it was
like sick
um so i hope like he took all that with
him because it was looked like an
expensive
you know journey yes or maybe he kept it
so he has like you know somewhere to go
if he ever wants to crash there
also like he is dating phoebe like
daphne one of the eligible bachelorettes
in hollywood like i don't think she's
going to staten island to see pete
davidson at his mom's house you know
i mean i don't even think she's going to
stand island period just saying
yeah but like she must be if they're
dating yeah no like pete davidson must
be like really hot if like she's going
to she's taking the ferry you know
hundred percent there's only one way to
get to staten island the ferry 100
um yeah but so they're really cute
they're a cool couple everybody's
shipping
i know but like we get a picture of them
like how do we know that they're
actually dating there's just so many
headlines i've not seen them in the same
room the last time i doubted like a
relationship
just because of the headlines let me
guess about pete davidson
oh ariana grande yeah i was just like
there's no [ __ ] way that this is true
and i was so [ __ ] wrong
so no this is believable but like we're
talking about it so much and i haven't
seen a goddamn photo
yeah where is it show us photos yeah
show us photos
maybe it's like an online relationship
right like pen pals that's cute
really cute have you heard of pen pal i
don't think so
no me neither i feel like i missed out
on something
why don't you ask for one yeah i can
start writing to inmates
that's what a lot of people do yeah and
they get married like via mail
it's crazy it's a good journey for you
yeah i think so
are you ready for our next story it's so
many components of your least favorite
things i couldn't help but choose it
okay aaron rodgers holds shayleen
woodley's at disney world
while enjoying disney world together
yeah okay
it's the most magical place on earth
with the cutest duo for claudia asher
and opposite daddy yeah
wait did i say i don't like them as a
couple um
you're just like not about them i just i
don't understand them i understand them
but i'm just like
not about them personally and that's
fine i'm so happy for like
them and i hope that they have a lasting
relationship and then they're enjoying a
fun-filled easter weekend together at
disney world in orlando florida
were they with any nieces or nephews
like young kids or just two adults it
didn't appear
nieces and nephews it did not appear
that there were nibblings on site
so um i really don't want to get into
this like whole thing because i had like
a community of people like
attack me when i spoke out against
adults who go to disneyland
and by the way like that's fine
like if you want to go to disneyland on
easter like for a special occasion like
that's fine
i was really talking about like the
people who like go like almost every
weekend and like move to orlando to be
near the parks and like
you know and like know all these special
facts about disneyland and world like
that's more what i was talking about
um i think this is like a fine activity
they appear to just be like looking cute
um so although i i definitely was
triggered by the photos i didn't really
have a problem with them choosing this
as an easter activity like
that's what disneyland is for like
special occasions not like you know
every weekend okay
i think it's fair me too and the
pictures are really cute
i know they look really cute i like
loved her outfit even though i was like
wondering how hot she was because like
they went to la or orlando either way
though so [ __ ] hot like yeah and a
long sleeve turtleneck and big chunky
jeans and doc martens
like that is a choice yeah yeah no
that's really true
so that's what i was thinking about but
i thought they looked cute in their
matching hats and they've been like
really like active on social now just
like kind of like flaunting their
relationship which means they're like
comfortable and like
i actually really have grown to um
appreciate no less than that like
what'd you say tolerate yes
tolerate you know the relationship
because at first i'm like this makes no
sense and like honestly this will be
over in a second
but now they're like really kind of
standing the test of time and being like
cute and stuff
and i just i'm obsessed with aaron
rodgers so like i trust him
and i'd like to know nothing about
chilean woodley but what i do know is
that like her and i would not be friends
you know what i mean
i don't think there's actually a single
person on this earth who i have less in
common with and like
would have less to talk about like she
would hate me and like i would probably
hate her too you know what i mean
yes like she's like you know got so
famous and so rich and like gave up all
of her material items like that's
literally the last thing i would do like
if i became like a mega star rich
celebrity like the opposite so we just
like are different types of girls so
that's why i didn't really like
understand it but it's also like you
couldn't ever be like her because you're
not like other girls
so that's what we discovered yesterday
yeah you're right so there couldn't be a
girl who was like you i'm
just like not like other girls but you
know what i think shaylene is also not
like other girls
she's definitely in a way that's
different from the way that you're not
like other girls of course because we're
not like each other
right yeah no i completely agree yeah so
this is like
cute this is key i'm not like building a
ship by any means
but i will let them through my port 100
i will let them through my suze canal
that literally sounds like so phallic
100 yeah
it's like i'm not personally here for
like them
because i'm not i don't like i'm not
obsessed with one of them
on their own but i do always appreciate
like the
convergence of different aspects of fame
yes like sports and film yes so
to me i like that and aaron rodgers has
been just like in the news a lot because
he's been one of like the most popular
guest hosts on jeopardy oh i've been
seeing
and i just think it's so interesting
like because there's also this clip
that's gone viral of
one um they did like celebrity jeopardy
he was on with mr wonderful
and someone else as contestants and
there's this clip because he got like
literally every answer in a row like
from history to english like it was
actually so impressive
and so now he's just like kind of like a
jeopardy icon and he's
really well liked as the um guest host
and i know like there's a lot of you
know things up in the air like guest
host like
his name like he i mean he's busy
obviously but like he could do it
wow that's so interesting it sounds to
me like he's not like other guys
no no no no he's not like other guys and
honestly he's
not like other nfl players like at all
yeah that's the vibe
that i've gotten in trying to understand
the rogers of it all the rogers
and then there's also like the whole
other added element like where do we
land with the rogers family the jordan
and jojo of it all like are they talking
that other brother luke who like didn't
play professional sports but had the
same haircut as them and like
all that drama where they like were you
know yelling at each other for not
calling their mom on easter last year
like
where did we land with that and then
this easter he went to disney world
without his family yeah and do we know
what jordan and jojo did
they look like they've been on vacation
last i saw i don't follow them
i follow jojo they they were on vacation
do we have a speaking of the bachelor do
we have the story about lauren
and ahri's no because i wasn't going to
dignify them with another let's just
address it because we gave them a story
yesterday basically saying they
announced they're moving to hawaii
when they did a whole vlog that said
we're moving to hawaii and now they're
coming out on their instagrams and being
like
oh my god like sorry we caused so much
confusion like we're not moving to
hawaii we're just getting a vacation
house
that's not news like you didn't need to
vlog that no
and you didn't need to be so misleading
i feel stupid and misled
it kind of feels like they misled us on
purpose like just like legislate
yeah so i yeah just correction they're
not going to update you
it's just an issuing a correction but
i'm not spending more time talking about
it because i feel so bad
what about um rachel and matt is that a
story no what's the latest
on dumas they were spotted in new york
together yesterday
what yeah it's shocking it is
groundbreaking it is
shattering blurry from the back but but
this photo is a photo yeah
oh my god no i did not see that so if
you're in new york like
matt lives downtown your eyes peeled
peel maybe we need to do some
on the boots on the ground investigation
also just like keep your eyes abreast
definitely jeez definitely keep your
breasts
alive okay fifth and final story
rapper will i am is selling a smart mask
for 299 dollars
oh but when we sold 25 dollar masks it
was out of touch
yeah remember that rapper william wants
to make face masks a high-end high-tech
statement the black eyed peas
i'm so bothered by this me too the black
eyed peas member announced this week
he's teaming up with honeywell
to launch super mask it's super mass but
it's with an x i'm saying supermass
yeah that's probably right or it's super
mask
and you have to go like this with your
head super mask
a 299 mask with tons of bells and
whistles in addition to
dual three-speed fans and hepa filters a
type of mechanical air filter
it features bluetooth connectivity led
day glow lights noise canceling audio
and microphone capabilities
seven hours of battery life and a
magnetic earbud docking system it also
comes with adjustable straps
this is the super mask oh it's kind of
cute
mask headphones tech robot it's like it
has a fan for your mouth
yes i guess it has like a filtration
system so here's the thing like honestly
this
sounded dumb when you first described it
but now it's like okay i could see
people like
needing that or wanting it but i'm like
like i'm a little nervous like people
are now like making more masks because
like
when are we done with the maps like i
thought like this isn't like we're
on our way out of the mask and i know i
heard vouchers say like even if you're
double vaccinated and like everyone in
the room is vaccinated and you're
standing outside there's 99 people in a
room
yeah like you still have to wear the
mask i heard that
but we eventually plan to not wear masks
right so i was just like
what was disheartening to me about this
story is that like there's new mass
companies coming out which means like
we're not
close to being done there's no
investment investments being made in the
mass industry
the mass industry should be on the
decline right now like mask sales should
be going
down they had their time no i'm just
confused and i'm sure like there's a
whole cdc
who article about it but like i'm sure
there's really not
for me i'm just like isn't the point of
you know moving out of the pandemic like
hopefully to never wear masks again like
it's just going to become permanent like
i'm really going to cry like
because i and i'm not an anti-master i
can't stress that enough like i want my
mask i respect me
we know but i'm not going to lie and say
i like it like i literally hate it
so [ __ ] much so what the [ __ ] do we
do
yeah so he said it like because i'm sure
you know it's the timing is a little
precarious for this new
high-tech match okay his new role as a
mass designer comes as some states have
started lifting mandatory mass mandates
amid the rise of
coveted vaccinations still some experts
say americans won't be setting masks
aside anytime soon
what do the experts say william said to
the new york times
sars happened in japan and southeast
asia and they got over it and they still
wear masks so
i guess the whole that's a cultural
thing they've worn masks in
asian countries for as long as i can
remember yeah no
never for him is that like people post
covid will still
want to wear masks okay i i agree
because copen was terrible
but i'm not gonna be one of those people
i really like that's
i'm looking forward to going to concerts
and never wearing a mask again like dead
seriously like i [ __ ] hate masks yeah
but i believe that we should wear them
like i can't stress that enough
yeah until it's but i'm not looking for
like bigger better
yeah i just feel like the time for masks
like might be up sooner rather than
later
like it should be on the decline yeah so
i just think like if he had launched
a year ago billion dollar company like
huge mistake will i am
huge so that's what my thoughts are i
agree
um okay we're gonna recap real
housewives of dallas and then dive into
deer toasters and the real housewives of
dallas recap is brought to you by flex
flex is innovating period care with
products that are body safe
made for comfort and keep you moving
first product is a flex
disc which is a one-time use menstrual
disc that fits perfectly inside your
body
one of the flex discs can be worn for up
to 12 hours
and it holds as much flow as three super
tampons it's not a cup and it's better
than a tampon it's unlike any other
period products you've seen before plus
you can wear it for mess free period sex
your white sheets will thank you
flex discs it's hard to say flex discs
also create
60 percent less waste compared to pads
and tampons so you can consider using
flex your environmental good deed
and if you want to go completely zero
waste and have the planet love you even
more
you can pick up the flex cup a reusable
menstrual cup that cosmo rated number
one
the patented pull tab makes flex the
only cup in the market
that removes like a tampon it's so easy
and you already know how to use it
it's disability friendly and made with
beginners in mind
it's velvety soft completely body safe
and lasts for years
with helpful videos in depth diagrams
gifs and flex births
you can walk through the entire process
with their experts and you'll never have
to go back to products from the past
once you try
flex so say goodbye to period say
goodbye to cramps
put sex back on the table and lend
mother nature a hand go to flexfits.com
toast and use the code toast for twenty
percent off the flex
disc starter kits or ten percent off
your first
flex cup plus free us shipping that's
code toast
at flex flex fits dot com
slash toast flexfits.com
toast love it okay real housewives of
dallas
so i really felt like real house as of
dallas this week was a really good
episode because it gave me like what i
really ex
wanted when i started watching real
housewives of dallas like
counter girls and they weren't being
like prissy about anything like
the fishing the off-roading the bigfoot
hunting
the house like it was the rv like when
the rv pulled up and brandi got in the
driver's seat like i was
shocked no it was hysterical and then
deandra could drive it too
there were so many great like visuals
during the
episode like the girls in the rv the
girls fishing like when there are three
of them sitting on the rock like
laughing crying drinking michelob ultra
brandy falls in and tiffany's wearing
her umbrella hat like that is was just
like
an amazing visual and when brandy fell
in like for me that was the pinnacle of
the episode one because i left so hard
when those guys were like pulling her
out by her overalls and i didn't realize
the reason why she fell was because
water got inside her overall she
literally could have drowned
and two the reason she got in the water
is because she thought she could just
grab the fish that
carrie snapped off of like it was just
the perfect like
kind of southern moment for me no i
agree and like
typically if i were on that trip i
probably would have
leaned towards going to the wine
experience which was so atrocious like
i thought the same thing i'm like
there's no way i would have chosen
fishing and then after i was like
these girls had a better day 100 and
they got home early
not even because the wine was like
bathtub wine like
even if they had just been like out of
vineyards literally made and why
even in the bathtub even if they had
just been out like a vineyard that was
like what we
like think of as a vineyard and they're
just sitting around drinking wine like
the fishing looked
more fun i know even though they had to
like hike to the fish and i was like i
don't know no and the fact that like
this fishing expedition was so
like obviously fun looking but it seemed
like an emotionally like
liberate healing experience like carrie
came away from it
she didn't about face yeah like from the
morning to like crying to stephanie
being so sorry
and then tiffany had such a wonderful
moment where she was like
realized she had girlfriends and then in
her confessional she was like you're not
like right pledging the sorority like
you're in like yeah
i agree like like i it just was so
it was such a heartwarming moment it was
like in the day and they were just like
doing the most in that day like they
woke up so hungover up till three
when fishing went to the winery came
back and now they have the redneck relay
like
it's just a lot like stephanie really
jam-packed this trip but it's very clear
that like
all of the activities in like oklahoma
and the people are like so
near and dear to stephanie's heart and i
was not surprised that like and
stephanie doesn't really kind of like
start fights or take anything personally
but
i was not surprised at all that she
reacted the way that she did to carrie
being so unbelievably disrespectful and
rude
actually like acting like a beast
towards this guy charles who was
just like a nice low-key not like simple
guy
who was just coming to like share his
experience with
with the women like it was so i like
don't like die for carrie
it was so disappointing and so
disgusting and like i know exactly what
stephanie was feeling like she's like i
invited this guy like i it was my name
like i
invited him and like he left feeling
humiliated humiliated he came on
like and now he's gonna be on tv like
with this woman saying you probably have
a little penis
it was just embarrassing for him like
and it's obviously embarrassing for
stephanie but like i didn't even
invite this man to my trip in oklahoma
and i'm embarrassed i'm embarrassed i
feel so weird i feel so like sad for him
like
that he just like came to like help like
give these girls a fun night and this
like not only the small pee pee comment
but also like
coming at him for hunting hunting
shaming when it's like
this is their way of life like don't go
into someone's community and like judge
what they do like that's what the
lifestyle is that's what they're doing
just like this air of superiority when
it's like are you a vegan
no right you literally had a hot dog 25
minutes ago so someone else killed what
you ate that doesn't make you a better
person
now honestly it makes you a coward you
can even face the dog that you killed
for your hot dog
pig whatever yeah actually a hot dog is
scrap meat so it's actually a bunch of
different animals
oh good okay good carrie yeah that
really pissed me off
you weren't like doing anything by
taking a stance against hunting when you
are a meat eater and you just
don't kill what you eat yeah so i like
i i think she really thought she was
doing something even the next day with
fishing like wait my mars and ethics
like what are we doing with the fish
i know i think she was like trying to
come off really good on the show and
ended up
like i just felt like her motivations
for this trip were like to
come off like a hero to the audience and
she ended up coming off like a villain
you know
yeah yeah no it was so
so wrong next week they bring him back i
know which gives me even more of a pit
like
this poor man i know but like maybe they
can make it right like maybe if carrie
is
very um apologetic and contrite maybe
they can have a great night with him you
know hopefully
knocking back some beers redneck really
maybe he joins in on the fun
okay like i hope so but like i'm like
why is this man coming back like he's
been humiliated
enough no it literally like hurt it was
so painful to watch
hurt me at my core at my core like
terrible and on tv you know like just
humiliating and everywhere like i
totally
understood everything stephanie was
saying everything she was feeling the
fact that she like spent the whole night
crying she's just like such a nice
person 100
yes and she's like so unique because
nice is boring but she's not boring like
she planned an amazing party
she's friends with all of the women like
she's so rich like she's really like my
favorite and i just like she's so
sensitive and like i
really felt exactly what she was feeling
yeah but she also like doesn't speak up
a lot so when she does like take it
down and listen carrie no carrie like
literally coming in deandra your eggs
look disgusting and then laughing
while like stephanie's been crying all
night like laughing in her face
out of control and i mean the only
different like the only thing is that i
don't know how stephanie was like so
forgiving even though carrie was like
so apologetic but the problem is that
like
carrie probably wouldn't have done any
of that stuff if she was sober
um and so now it's just like the
question like she really becomes a
different person when she drinks and
that's like we've seen that sometimes on
housewives where it's like
you're literally completely different
person at night than you are in the
morning and it makes it like difficult
to follow a story line because you're
inconsistent like
in how you feel so not even on the story
line it's like if you're friends with
someone and you love them
sober and you can't stand them drunk and
they drink a lot
yeah and a lot like what do you do no i
know it's like difficult
yeah i don't know i wouldn't be able to
just like groundhog's day every morning
pretend like the day before like
didn't happen right so that's what i
feel like we're getting into almost like
a cycle with carrie
and that's gonna be like annoying it's
going to be a challenge yeah and she's i
but it does seem like
when aside from in the morning but like
when
she apologized about the egg's comment
which was a trivial comment i didn't i
wasn't i didn't even think anything
about it i wasn't waiting like it was no
when she said it i was like you're so
[ __ ] mean yeah but that's just her
but i wasn't waiting for an apology so
it does seem like
she's capable of acknowledging her wrong
which is huge
unlike wonder medley yeah like she's the
pinnacle of like
why being such an absolute beast with no
remorse gets you kicked off the show
and so carrie was a beast but she also
had remorse so we have no choice but to
respect that we really do we really do
so as if she can make things right with
um
the biggest hunter i can move forward i
just um
i'm really liking this trip like i'm
looking forward to next week i think
this was like a really good trip for the
women
these women have so much stamina i know
i cannot believe it the fact that they
drove eight hours and then they were up
like having dinner until 1am and then
they went
bigfoot hunting like what no i know
stephanie like jam-packed the [ __ ] out
of this trip
yeah that and who knew like georgia was
so close to oklahoma i mean i guess a
lot of people probably know that but i
did not
texas you mean what did i say georgia
yeah texas and oklahoma sorry yeah they
i think i believe they share a border
but it was like
a long an eight-hour trip in an rv and
they like we're driving like terribly
like i'm sure a normal person could have
gotten there in six
yeah well it depends where in texas
you're coming from anywhere in oklahoma
yeah yeah that's true
um but all in all it was actually a good
episode and i've been pretty hard on the
dallas housewives thus far because it's
been like a mediocre season
but things seem like they might be
turning around the trip always picks
things up
always and this is like just a good trip
like this is this is what i wanted like
i wanted
dallas housewives to be fighting about
christ and doing red like not to be so
stereotypical but like
that's what i wanted like yeah i wanted
fights about church and going to
oklahoma like
that's what i live for because that is
not the entire but that's a lot of what
goes on
in the south yeah but i was getting very
stressed out at some of like this trip
just the stamina that's required the
hungoverness i know
the everybody's sharing rooms like
sharing beds too
yeah which is it's a big house no i know
i thought it was a cute house
i thought it was really cute i feel like
we should go no that was literally my
next thought like
looking it up yeah um okay well that was
the dallas recap and now we can dive
into deer toasters which is our advice
segment so we do this every wednesday
here at the morning toast it's called
your toasters and if you ever want to
write in all of these
all of these submissions are from our
listeners dear toasters at gmail.com is
the email we can keep it anonymous we
can change names you let us know and
also if you've written us in recently
make sure to send us a update okay first
up dear toasters
you are beautiful stunning you are
beautiful smart
but no we're not you are stunning smart
beautiful and everything of the sort i
come to you my gurus because i need
serious help on this issue with my
boyfriend
here's some background we've been dating
for over a year and we live together
we're 26 years old my boyfriend can be
controlling he's very jealous and
possessive and has made me burn bridges
with a lot of men from my past
some hookups and flanks but mostly just
guy friends i didn't necessarily want to
do this but this
but it was a compromise i made oh my god
sorry i'm having such a hard time
reading today
no worries take your time you know when
i said i thought
i might be dyslexic i'm like having like
like words are like moving let me see
let me see maybe it's the size of the
font no no it's the same as always i'm
just like
my eyes are doing weird things like
yeah ice could be weird sometimes yeah
okay when you're trying to focus so
like intensely on something they mix you
up i didn't
necessarily want to do this but it was a
compromise i made to make the
relationship work
now imagine my frustration when i
noticed my boyfriend is still in contact
with his ex's family
he regularly snapchats his ex's brother
and they even hung out recently
he also snapchats the sister and she dm
responds to like everything he posts on
instagram
he dated his ex for about 10 years
starting in middle school so he uses i
grew up with them were close as his
reason for keep talking to them
his ex has moved on living with another
guy they broke up three years ago so i'm
not worried about her
i just find it unfair that he thinks he
can talk to people from his past when i
can't
he thinks that all my male friends just
want to sleep with me and that's just
really not true
am i being crazy and petty that i don't
want to talk to his ex's family
especially if
if i'm being so restricted on who i'm
allowed to talk to what do you think
love an extremely annoyed toaster no no
you're not being dramatic
at all you're not being dramatic at all
like i really am so sorry to you and i'm
sorry to this man but i hate your
boyfriend
your boyfriend hate hate like first when
he's being controlling and like doesn't
want you to
um talk to exes or have guy friends like
that's [ __ ] weird and like we were
gonna
we were gonna work on that but the fact
that then he is literally still in
contact with his ex of 10 years his
family like
the hypocrisy at least but i had a
problem with it even before the
hypocrisy
if you're going to be crazy be
consistent yeah apply
crazy apply those same standards to
yourself but if you're holding one
person to one standard that crazy
[ __ ] standard
and then being so lacks with yourself it
the inconsistency it's going to be a
no from me it's going to be the in sorry
it's the inconsistency for me
and so now you need to look inward and
ask yourself if you can live without
this man
because i think that maybe you should
yeah because i think even before like
the fact that he was being so
hypocritical
before that like anyone who restricts
who you can talk to like
there's there's being controlling and
i'm contr i am controlling
but then there's being possessive and i
don't think that's a good quality
especially in a man
and i think it's like a it's a it's just
a big red flag
so it's a red flag but and a and
it's something that needs to be worked
through and worked on but if you hadn't
said the second
half of the story i would have been like
okay if you guys are just in this kind
of like controlling relationship where
you guys don't
talk to like i would assume he didn't
have females that he's talking to like
maybe that's something that you can work
on together maybe
a little bit of counseling are you
talking to him explaining like something
you know i wouldn't just set throw in
the towel but like the fact that he
is a [ __ ] inconsistent controlling
mess i'm not interested
for you i really hate this man and i
hate this man and um
i'm sorry if that's not like what you
wanted to hear me but but if you're
writing to us like you knew something is
a mess i'm sorry something is amazing
and i just
i i feel like we never give the advice
to break up with somebody no we really
always try to make it work
but i don't like any bit of this and if
you're like the fabulous
toaster that you are you deserve so much
better to live free like that's
not normal 10 years from middle school
yeah like get a life we're like old now
okay
next up dear claudia and jackie i am
having in-law family drama
a few months ago my husband and i
planned a small family dinner for our
daughter's birthday
nothing fancy just pizza and birthday
cake that sounds like
the best party ever i was an ice cream
cake
it was supposed to be our parents and
siblings only due to cobid we wanted to
keep it small but still celebrate her
birthday
my mother-in-law brought my husband's
grandmother without telling us as we
didn't invite any of the grandparents
i was a little annoyed that she did this
she seemed to think it was okay because
his grandmother is only one person when
i still have all four of my grandparents
living and i'm very close to them
a few days after the dinner my husband
gets a call from his cousin asking what
happened at our daughter's birthday
party
mind you it was not a party my husband
was confused by this and asked what they
were talking about as nothing dramatic
happened at the dinner his cousin tells
him that their grandmother
said i was rude to her and i didn't
greet her and no one talked to her the
whole time
and that the cousins have nothing to say
to me and won't associate with me
because i was rude to his grandmother
when my husband came to me with this i
was taken aback and hurt
as i did not do anything to his
grandmother i didn't hug her as i
usually would pre-covered but with covet
i was trying to keep my distance
everyone saw that i wasn't rude to the
grandmother at the birthday dinner so i
was a little confused by this
fast forward a few months later now that
some of us are vaccinated
this cousin is now making it a point not
to invite me and my husband to family
outings or outdoor barbecues
my husba my husband's cousin makes it a
point to invite all the other cousins
except for us
it really doesn't hurt my feelings as i
personally don't care
but i can tell it bothers my husband
that our daughter is being left out of
time with her family
am i crazy or am i in the middle of some
petty situation for something i didn't
do it wrong
should i apologize for something i
didn't do what do you suggest i could
really use your help on this
sincerely a confused toaster so like
part of me like wants to be petty but
also like you have a daughter and like
it's really is not fair that like
they're leaving her out of
cousin events because like cousins are
an integral part of your childhood so
as much as i want you to be like i love
that you don't care because like it's
your husband's family like i'm so glad
we don't also have to like placate your
feelings of like know like living for
your realism
yes um but it's not fair to your
daughter you're right so honestly like
family is tough but just like do what
you have to do to make it right because
you don't care so great yeah i would say
like
caring is the best thing it doesn't
sound like you need to apologize because
it's still like i don't see what you did
wrong and like this dramatic granny like
needs to like the draining jeremy like
i just i can't believe a grammy could be
so dramatic and like i know and
it would be so like petty and focused
calculated
no it's like it's just it's the kid's
birthday like
she hugged you she didn't hug you also
like no offense grammar like it's not
about you
no i know so like and it sounds like
granny has like a lot of
great grandchildren and she's being
petty grandma right it's her husband's
grandmother therefore it's
her daughter's great-grandmother right
so you would think like she's above the
drama but no
she's not also at some point like in age
like you do
get to be above the drama just because
you're like literally
too old for it but i kind of admire the
hell out of great granny over here
because she's like you know kicking it
in her 90s and
sneaking it all about still starting
drama all that granny that's actually
like what i aspire to be like
such a self-absorbed grandma like making
every kid's birthday party
about me 100 but you don't want your
husband to be feeling some type of way
you don't want your kid to miss out on
these times
so just like do you have to drunk
wherever the issue is coming from be
like
listen i don't want there to be animus
between the family like i'm sorry that
granny felt some type of way
i was just trying to don't even make it
about like my grandparents weren't
invited just be like i was trying to
avoid coping restrictions even though
like that's why i thought you were going
with this
and that really bothered me too you
don't care you don't actually need to
like share how you're feeling
you know but the fact that you have four
grandparents and they couldn't be at
your daughter's party but somehow like
other grandma from the in-laws got
invited like that bothers me but if you
bring that up
then you're telling granny that she was
right that you did feel some type of way
and that you did treat her differently
because
upset you know what i'm saying don't
bring that up but i haven't i just
wanted to like not let that slide but
yeah
big [ __ ] problem now like you've been
saying that you didn't treat granny some
type of way so you can't you can't
justify
i treat i was weird to granny because i
felt some type of way no be like i
literally was not rich to granny like i
was so glad she came
and like i'm so sorry it's like my cove
like say like my social
i'm just like feeling socially awkward
and i didn't know like this is like so
not a big deal
your cousins are being so [ __ ]
dramatic advice is to squash it
say what you need to say get the kid
back in the parties
no like poor little amabel is being
he's being left out of the cousin
festivities and that's not okay because
the nibblings are waiting for emma bell
yeah and it's like not fair to the
nibblings that they're not getting to
hang out with your amazing
kid yeah and i bet ambell has like such
amazing energy 100
okay this is our first our final one
you know what you need to do you need to
tell granny it's not that deep
no literally grandma like it and also
grandma it's not about you like that's
really the moral of the story it doesn't
sound like granny's gonna respond to
that no no no
long time listener first time caller
love you in the show so much and this is
why your advice is very pertinent to my
situation okay
last week there was a pga golf
tournament in my neighborhood needless
to say
a good time was had by all not to hear
unfortunately i found myself in the
middle of some drama
there was a couple who are new to the
neighborhood oh this neighborhood sounds
like everything sounds like the
beginning of an amazing book
yeah yes there was a couple who are new
to the neighborhood
jen and ted they were fighting all
weekend long at different events in the
tournament
jen found dating apps on ted's phone and
messages proving he'd been cheating on
her right before the weekend
cuts is saturday night and he shows up
to a party with a single girl from our
neighborhood that we all know
betty oh my god this really does sound
like a book betty was definitely
overserved and had no idea this guy was
in a relationship with jen and that they
were having drama
it turned into a huge fight and they
made a scene and they were all kicked
out of the party
later that night i found myself in a
conversation with ted at another party
where my husband and i were casually
hanging with close friends ted started
to mouth off about his exploits and i
had enough i told him he was a
loser and no one in town respects him
and a few other
and a few other mean albeit true
comments he proceeds to find my husband
and tell him what a [ __ ] i am
then they get into a fight because oh my
god then they get into a fight because
my husband was defending me and ted
punches my husband in the face
we leave the party and i was so
embarrassed and upset about the whole
thing
well my husband and i tried to not talk
about it all week or glorify fighting so
we kept it pretty quiet
but all week i was getting calls from
people telling me lots of gossip and the
story somehow turned into that
i punched ted if only
what should i do leave it alone clear my
name i'm so over being in this drama but
at the same time
i don't want my name sullied all over my
new all over my somewhat small town
a toaster seeking justice before we get
in
i need to know where you live because
this is the life i want
i want to have golf tournaments on the
weekend with tons of parties where men
are fighting over women and men are
cheating like
i want this stupid drama we went from
one party to the next and at this party
it was close to girlfriends and at that
party they were kicked out
it's like where are you living that
there's multiple parties per week i
could barely find one party to go to 100
let us know um here's my advice like
you're in a small town it sounds like
you and your husband
like you run this town that's what it
sounds like to me based on
i didn't get that vibe oh really no it's
like ted and jen
are new did you even say they weren't
married or they're just a couple that's
like probably broken up because
he's cheating on her uh they are a
couple
like i think you like if the story comes
your writing someone's like saying i
heard this like definitely correct them
but don't worry about letting everyone
know because like ted sounds like a
literal monster and he's going to let
his color show too and he has more to
prove to the town than you do you said
it's your hometown no it's like the
cream
always rises the truth will come out and
ted's going to show who he is to other
people and then people are going to
start to see like you were just
um a victim of the situation and by the
way you should reach out and maybe make
an ally with jen not only because you
were defending her but like also now you
have a common enemy
yeah todd yeah ted ted yeah so
um i would just say correct anyone like
who's
coming to you incorrect but don't go
like on a mission too
yeah wait for it to play out because
ted's gonna expose himself don't you
worry about it
trash always take themselves out did we
learn nothing from the facebook group
um good luck to you and again can't
stress enough where do you live
yeah that's the takeaway thank you to
everyone who wrote in and to everyone
who didn't write us an update every week
i like get my cards thinking we're gonna
have an update and we don't
please email us to your toasters
gmail.com if we in the last year
have read a query of yours on this show
i would love to hear how things worked
out
please email us deartoasters gmail.com
and again if you're just looking for
some good old advice got something you
got
trouble deciding on dear toasters
gmail.com
yeah and that's our show that is our
show
we will see you tomorrow for another one
of our shows
it'll be ours right yeah i think it
won't be anyone else's
how could it be it's ours thank you guys
so much for listening to the morning
toast the millennial morning show where
we deliver the fast five stories that
you need to know every monday through
friday on youtube so if you're watching
this on youtube please feel free to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available as a podcast and
where podcasts can be found so it's a
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
have radio cast box all the places so
wherever you listen to podcasts find us
the morning shows and leave a five star
review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are we hope you
have an amazing day don't forget to hump
someone you love we will see you
tomorrow
bye goodbye